ما هو الهدف في نهاية المطاف
من هذه الرحلة ، فهناك الكثير على
جدول أعماله بما في ذلك بالطبع رحلته إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية التالية ، فما هو الهدف العام ،
أفترض أن هناك ثلاثة
أشياء رئيسية
سيناقشونها ويأملون أن أه  تأكد
من أه التقدم في كل منهم ، لذا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء أه إيران أه هذا
سيكون شيئًا سيناقشونه
مطولاً ، لا يزال هناك مسافة
بين الموقف الإسرائيلي الذي
لا ينبغي للولايات المتحدة أن تنضم إلى
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني  وأيضًا الولايات المتحدة
وبالطبع لدينا تعهد من الرئيس
بايدن في مسار الحملة الانتخابية بأنه
سينضم إليها مرة أخرى لذلك لا تزال هناك مسافة
بينهما هناك ، لكنها أكثر من ذلك بكثير
دعنا نقول
أه طريقة دبلوماسية ودبلوماسية للتعامل مع الأمور
مقارنة عندما يكون هناك  كان رئيسًا للوزراء
نتنياهو الذي ستتذكرونه ذهب
للكونغرس بفعالية على رأس
الرئيس آنذاك باراك أوباما لمحاولة
إقناع الأمريكيين بعدم التوقيع
على الاتفاق النووي الإيراني بحيث
المسألة الأولى والثانية بالطبع
لن تقوم إسرائيل بتطبيع
العلاقات مع المملكة العربية السعودية في أي وقت قريب
لكننا نتوقع بعض الخطوات الصغيرة
للخروج من هذه الرحلة أه على سبيل المثال
السماح للطائرات الإسرائيلية بالتحليق فوق
الأجواء السعودية  والمسلمون الذين يسافرون من
إسرائيل سيكونون قادرين على الذهاب مباشرة إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية للمشاركة في
الحج علاوة على ذلك ذكرت
أننا كنا نتحدث عن
أنظمة الدفاع الصاروخي هنا في الرئيس
الإسرائيلي بايدن وكذلك الحصول على عرض توضيحي
لـ  القبة الحديدية سوف نحصل على
عرض توضيحي لنظام الدفاع الصاروخي الليزري الجديد ذو الشعاع الحديدي
، والفكرة
هي أنه لن يحمي إسرائيل
من التهديدات مثل إيران
ووكلائها فحسب ، بل سيحمي أيضًا
حلفائها الإقليميين أيضًا ، ثم أخيرًا
سيحمي الرئيس الفلسطيني بايدن
بالطبع سوف نرى محمود عباس
رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
مرة أخرى. لا تتوقع أي إنعاش
لعملية السلام والمرابط التي يديرها بايدن.
الحصص التموينية لن تستحوذ على هذا
القراص ولكن ربما تتوقع المزيد من
الإعلانات في محاولة تحسين
الكثير من الفلسطينيين المزيد من الدعم
للفلسطينيين اقتصاديًا من
إدارة بيدن وقد رأينا بالفعل
أه تأثير هذه الرحلة
ببعض إجراءات بناء الثقة
الإجراءات المعلنة الليلة الماضية من
إسرائيل جديدة أه تصاريح بناء
منازل مثلا والمزيد من تصاريح
العمل للفلسطينيين أيضا